[Music]
in wrong place wrong time news ah
submitted by the chair master mmm a
lunchtime running club ran down and
caught a thief time running club oh I
think people buy just during lunch time
though hey little one school and I was
like what the [ __ ] wants to run during
like a school life here's running club
sounds - these are grownups
okay yeah so this lunchtime running
group uh they they were getting ready to
run because they like running you're
running enthusiast when you're probably
also like smelling like [ __ ] in the
second half of the work wants to have
showers in their office like we do oh so
then that's when they saw that a man
sprinted at a very quick pace and so one
person said yeah you're not gone [ __ ]
past me yeah they're saying no because
they were waiting so they hadn't gone
yet so they were waiting for one more of
the members and then that's when this
man sprinted by them they said they were
probably running at a 7:15 case that's
pretty fast 7:15 a mile pace that's
pretty fast
15 miles an hour running the mile as if
they would have finished in and right
7:15 7.15 seconds like seven miles I
mean seven minutes and 15 seconds a sea
7:15 though like why the [ __ ] do we need
the 50 cuz you're [ __ ] runners so I
like the rudder geek silly oh that's a
little bit slower than a 7 : yeah like
yeah :
yes the 18 seconds makes a big
difference yeah I'm doing it or running
because if you think about it like if
you do four laps that's 15 seconds I
know you're not talking to it like in
this report they're not talking to the
runners or talking to they're talking
around they were telling runners world
this is like
now I understand this rdik this is like
when I'm in the room and my two Air
Force brothers and they're both like
yeah well did you do CPT I added a CTC
and a DVD and I'm like [ __ ] you guys you
shut the [ __ ] up you muses start making
up your own acronyms for things I do
yeah you download OPP I'm like you guys
like APL stop your ADC so anyway so then
they were saying that they quickly
realize why this man was running at that
pace because this other man came behind
him saying like help help you just took
my stuff so he took my phone in my
laptop my man red just robbed me or
whatever so then this group sprinted
after that first dude that's like a
zombie and passed the wrong group of
things in Philadelphia just speed the
picture somewhere so I see a bunch of
pilgrim as for chasing that they've
tracked them so like they were going
down the streets and then they tracked
him until he ducked into a construction
site and then the one of the runner said
it was just like a movie with giant
machines and loud sounding ringing and
sparks flying everywhere oh you're
trying to keep our peace so we're like
look they're like waiting around but
still keepin the pace up like looking
under [ __ ] but keep this [ __ ] right yep
oh yeah exactly
I'll see their heart rate up nothing
over here yeah keep the heart rate that
beam that carries like the big old jump
over these so then like part of the
group tried to go to the far side of the
construction site to cut off the thief
which is a full city block around and
then what pace is that guy running it
yeah 647 he's the slowest one he's the
939 oh [ __ ] not the 9:30 got negative
you don't want okay yeah they're saying
that two other air people from the group
they started Kevin C canvassing the
neighborhood and then there were like
school buildings and rows of houses
around this college campus and they
found one with the high fence that
seemed like a prime place for dumping
the criminals loot is how they report it
and so these two people from the running
group started knocking on the door
trying to let the residents know that
the thief may we drop the stuff in their
backyard and so as they were going
inside the criminal took off from his
hiding place behind the bushes out front
and then they started chasing this thief
again right to him within one of the
guys that one of the guys from the
running club like he felt a snap and
[Applause]
then no go show these dudes and like and
chicks and like a little ass running
shorts this is happening done a lunch
break to their heroes yeah he's in the
back with the wheelchair now Marissa
guys maybe so then the race came to an
end because there were some cops that oh
my god sorry one second they just run
and join the group - yeah like it's a
rocky movie the whole neighborhood joins
them it's like a Village People music
video the suspect ran into the path of
responding University of Pennsylvania
police officers who then detained him
sounds like a Bollywood movie everybody
where they around the tree and the
criminals this way except it's a cactus
cactus in Philadelphia yeah so then like
the cops are saying like they were
yelling to other officers like it's a
running club this guy trying tried to
run from the running club wait one of
the people said that one of the officers
to my gun officer told another officer
oh yeah he was like dude this [ __ ]
funny
like what he tried running away from
this running club but yeah and then so
happy ending but then they were happy
ending there's Judd Apatow and all his
running buddies I wonder what kind of
company they are oh they did mention a
college campus new college campus
there's like the Faculty's faculties
yeah yeah or it's a lunch team no they
be working all shirt they're doing like
run off but yeah they're just saying
that they really like the running group
because then like they'll hold each
other accountable so they can everyone
could get their midday run in and that
they have the running club open to
anyone that wants to join us what this
is all a [ __ ] marketing scheme for
them it's not fake did they recover the
lost items in someone's backyard
oh good person I don't know it's pretty
interesting that they knew that they try
to ditch to the stuff in people's yards
and a specific one sounds like so with
the - Steve's in the way and that's
where they're so good at running
yeah spot yeah that's true yeah I
wouldn't dig that [ __ ] yeah this is a
product for somebody's fence over here
I'm like I'd be like what that's oddly
specific says Steve from the back yeah
well yes so they're just saying that
they probably would never do this again
but address yeah and they were saying
that they benefited from safety in
numbers and it's also relatively safe
near the college campus in the middle of
the day but Samaritan kind of act though
like everyone's getting together we got
to do something but it's like what do
you do will you actually catch the guy
because they don't no one prepares for
that [ __ ] like wait what do we do now if
we hold them like oh [ __ ] you obsessed
bites we make a citizen's arrest that
stopped called
boys have to stay with you
oh yeah totally telling all you got me
there then you could say sir but you're
performing citizen's arrest you may not
leave they run away you can say sir you
have no honor and then that will shame
him and make him turn around it don't
experience in this I'm very familiar
with the what about the citizen's arrest
one day be sick
that's God that's gonna be one of my you
just do it down to Ryan good he didn't
do anything wrong
true I want to say stop in the name of
the law
this is a citizen's arrest those two
lines now what if they go [ __ ] you and
you just walk away I'll be like that was
mean sir yeah I realize that's mean and
you're breaking although this is
citizens brutality then you being less
brutal this is a citizen's arrest blows
right by you
we should go citizen's arrest jaywalkers
they broke the [ __ ] law it's wrong oh
do [ __ ] like all we're cop uniforms and
like is gonna take a pretend police
sedan with a siren on pull people over
so when people are jaywalking we just
hit them with that car jump out like a
SWAT team with the [ __ ] riot shield
and we slam them down with it we're
gonna police brutality this skill will
come if you guys can fool them that you
think that to make them think that you
guys are some like police so you can be
on the thing like with your mouth we
rent a helicopter
we all wear military gear we fly into a
public location we get out and we go
into a building we come out with what
appears to be a bomb and we say it's a
nuclear device it has 30 seconds we
could not stop it in time and then
you're the guy with [ __ ] this poem
and we unscrew the [ __ ] and we get the
guy with the phone when he's [ __ ]
doing it and he's like three two one and
we all start hugging see if everyone
starts panicking like congregate in New
York City at the Miracle Mile geez
genius I want to do that to people that
are littering like we look for people
dude then the helicopter comes and then
[ __ ] five squad cars pull up they
start pulling guns on them and we slide
down from the [ __ ] helicopter we
start [ __ ] beating in their ass and
then handcuffing them and throw them in
the car or in the helicopter and then if
you end it with a quote and a statistic
then everyone will be under side if
you're like if you're like hey did you
know that this amount of littering
happens a year go keep it very like
reading dryly the carefree thing like
being like X amount of littering costs
that come that cost the city you have 1
million dollars a day and then like just
[ __ ] leave it that's like our New
York nuke idea if we end it with like
did you know that nuclear war takes out
this many people in all this [ __ ] so
you're so wrong to do nuclear war and it
was like oh they get mad talk it's a
social experiment it's just a frame for
statistically back social experiment to
make people think thank you aware did
you know and just because it's really
funny doesn't mean it's not making
people think
[Music]
[Music]